- Bem-vindo de volta a Entendendo
Informação e Computação Quântica.
Meu nome é John Watrous, e
sou o Diretor Técnico de Educação Quântica da IBM.
Esta é a quarta aula da série e é a última
aula da primeira unidade da série sobre os fundamentos
da informação quântica.
Até agora, falamos sobre
como a informação quântica funciona para sistemas simples e múltiplos, demos uma olhada no
modelo de circuit quântico,
e observamos algumas
limitações fundamentais da informação quântica.
Ao longo do caminho, encontramos
alguns conceitos matemáticos importantes,
incluindo produtos tensoriais e produtos internos, e vamos continuar
usando esses conceitos e vamos introduzir alguns novos
também, conforme precisarmos.
Nesta aula, vamos nos
concentrar em três exemplos fundamentais importantes: teletransporte quântico, codificação superdensa e o jogo CHSH,
que também é chamado de desigualdade CHSH e nem sempre é descrito como um jogo.
Esses não são apenas exemplos aleatórios
para ilustrar como a informação quântica funciona; eles realmente são partes essenciais da fundação
da informação quântica e
surgem em contextos diferentes e às vezes inesperados dentro da informação
e computação quântica.
O entrelaçamento desempenha um papel fundamental nos três
exemplos, e de fato, é o entrelaçamento que os faz funcionar
e os torna interessantes. Então, esta aula será, em certo sentido, nossa primeira oportunidade de
ver o entrelaçamento em ação
e começar a explorar o que torna o entrelaçamento tão interessante.
A visão geral da
aula é muito simples: vamos passar um por um
pelos três exemplos que acabei de mencionar,
teletransporte quântico,
codificação superdensa e o jogo CHSH.
Vamos discutir o que são essas coisas e o que as torna interessantes, e vamos fazer análises que explicam exatamente como elas funcionam
em nível matemático.
Antes de chegar ao primeiro
dos três exemplos, que é o teletransporte quântico, é apropriado primeiro
apresentar os personagens,
Alice e Bob, caso você
não esteja familiarizado com eles.
Alice e Bob são nomes
dados a entidades ou agentes hipotéticos em sistemas, protocolos, jogos,
e realmente qualquer outro tipo de interação que você queira considerar que envolva a troca de informação.
Eles surgiram pela primeira vez no
contexto da criptografia nos anos 1970, mas a
convenção de usar esses nomes dessa forma se tornou muito comum
em um contexto muito mais amplo desde então. A ideia é que esses
são nomes muito comuns, pelo menos em algumas partes do mundo, e começam com as letras A e B,
e também é conveniente
referir-se a Alice e Bob usando os pronomes "ela" e "ele", apenas por questão de brevidade.
Normalmente imaginamos que Alice e Bob estão em locais diferentes e que têm
objetivos e comportamentos diferentes
dependendo do que estamos falando.
Por exemplo, se estamos
falando sobre comunicação, ou seja, a transmissão de informação, podemos decidir
que Alice é a remetente
e Bob é o receptor
de qualquer informação que esteja sendo transmitida.
Às vezes Alice e Bob
cooperam — isso é muito típico —, mas às vezes eles
competem ou podem ter objetivos diferentes que podem
ou não ser consistentes
entre si, mas isso
tudo precisa ser deixado claro na situação em questão.
Claro, eles representam abstrações e não necessariamente seres humanos reais.
Também podemos introduzir
personagens adicionais como Charlie e
Diane ou nomes diferentes que representam
personas diferentes, como Eve
para uma bisbilhoteira ou Mallory para alguém agindo maliciosamente,
dependendo do contexto.
De qualquer forma, vamos ver Alice e Bob em todos os três
exemplos que discutiremos nesta aula e de vez em quando
ao longo do restante da série. Também vou fazer alguns
comentários sobre entrelaçamento antes de passar para os três exemplos.
Na aula dois, encontramos este exemplo de um estado entrelaçado de dois qubits.
É um dos quatro estados de Bell, e pode-se dizer que
este estado em particular representa o exemplo arquetípico
de um estado quântico entrelaçado.
Também encontramos este
exemplo de um estado probabilístico de dois bits.
É análogo ao
estado entrelaçado em certo sentido, mas não é entrelaçado;
o entrelaçamento é um fenômeno
exclusivamente quântico,
essencialmente por definição.
Existe uma definição matemática precisa do que é entrelaçamento e, basicamente, o que essa definição
diz é que o entrelaçamento
é uma correlação quântica não clássica.
Mas isso não é muito
útil em nível intuitivo; é uma definição de entrelaçamento em termos do que o entrelaçamento não é,
e provavelmente é por isso
que é genuinamente bastante difícil explicar o que o entrelaçamento é e o que o torna especial
em termos intuitivos.
Quando as pessoas tentam
explicar o que é o entrelaçamento em termos intuitivos, você
frequentemente ouve explicações que realmente não
distinguem esses dois estados
de forma significativa. Você pode ouvir a ideia
de que, se você mede um dos dois qubits entrelaçados,
então o estado do outro
é de alguma forma afetado instantaneamente, ou que o estado dos dois qubits não pode ser descrito separadamente
ou que os dois qubits
de alguma forma mantêm uma memória um do outro ou até mesmo que
eles estão emocionalmente ligados de alguma forma.
Mas por que essas propriedades
não são verdadeiras para este estado?
Esses dois bits estão intimamente conectados; cada um tem uma memória perfeita
do outro em sentido literal, mas
não é um estado entrelaçado.
Bem, uma forma de explicar o que
torna o entrelaçamento especial e o que torna este estado
muito diferente deste outro é explicar o que
podemos fazer com o entrelaçamento
ou o que podemos ver acontecendo
por causa do entrelaçamento que vai além das decisões que tomamos sobre como representamos nosso
conhecimento usando vetores.
Os três exemplos
que vamos discutir nesta aula têm essa natureza, pois ilustram
coisas que podemos fazer com entrelaçamento que
não conseguimos fazer com este estado
ou com qualquer estado correlacionado classicamente.
De fato, é muito típico no estudo da informação e computação quântica que vejamos o entrelaçamento como um recurso
por meio do qual diferentes
tarefas podem ser realizadas.
E quando fazemos isso, vemos este estado como representando
uma unidade de entrelaçamento.
Chamamos essa unidade de
entrelaçamento de e-bit; o "e" representa
entrelaçado ou entrelaçamento.
É verdade que são dois qubits, mas como quantidade de
entrelaçamento, é um e-bit.
Você também pode ver um par
de bits clássicos ordinários no estado probabilístico correlacionado
de antes como sendo um recurso que representa
um bit de aleatoriedade compartilhada.
Pode ser muito útil em
criptografia compartilhar um bit aleatório com alguém, presumindo
que ninguém mais saiba qual é esse bit, para que
ele possa ser usado como chave privada
ou como parte de uma chave privada, por exemplo, para fins de criptografia.
Mas nesta aula, nosso foco estará neste estado entrelaçado e
nas coisas que podemos fazer com ele.
E só para esclarecer a terminologia: quando dizemos que Alice
e Bob compartilham um e-bit, o que queremos dizer é que
Alice tem um qubit chamado A,
Bob tem um qubit chamado B, e juntos o par A, B
está no estado Phi plus.
Não importa quais nomes
escolhemos para os dois qubits; é claro que poderíamos
escolher nomes diferentes, mas ao longo desta aula,
vamos manter esses nomes
em prol da clareza. O primeiro exemplo da aula
é o teletransporte quântico,
ao qual daqui para frente vamos apenas
nos referir como teletransporte, por questão de brevidade.
O teletransporte é um protocolo que permite a um remetente
transmitir informação quântica a um receptor usando apenas entrelaçamento
e comunicação clássica para
realizar essa transmissão.
Não tem absolutamente nada a ver com a interpretação típica
da palavra teletransporte na ficção científica, que é que a matéria desaparece
em um lugar e aparece em outro.
O teletransporte quântico é apenas um nome que visa evocar isso como uma imagem ou como uma metáfora, por assim dizer.
O que está sendo teletransportado é
a informação quântica, não a matéria, e isso está acontecendo
por meio de uma transmissão de informação clássica
junto com entrelaçamento.
Para entender exatamente
como o teletransporte funciona, é útil começar
preparando o cenário, por assim dizer.
O que vamos fazer é imaginar um cenário envolvendo Alice e Bob, e
esse cenário é o seguinte:
Alice tem um qubit chamado Q que
ela gostaria de transmitir a Bob, o que significa que ela
quer que Bob segure em suas mãos
um qubit que está exatamente
no mesmo estado em que Q está quando eles começam o protocolo.
Em outras palavras, estamos falando sobre o problema fundamental da
transmissão de informação ou comunicação.
Temos uma remetente chamada Alice
e um receptor chamado Bob, e Alice quer enviar
informação quântica na forma de um qubit para Bob.
Há uma restrição, no entanto, que é que Alice não é
capaz de enviar fisicamente Q para Bob; tudo que ela pode fazer é enviar informação clássica para Bob.
Alice e Bob também têm
um recurso adicional, que é que compartilham um e-bit.
Então é esse o cenário; é
fácil imaginar situações em que a restrição de que
Alice não pode enviar Q fisicamente
para Bob é uma abstração razoável.
Se Alice e Bob estivessem em
continentes diferentes, por exemplo, ou se Alice não soubesse
a localização exata de Bob, então enviar fisicamente um qubit
provavelmente seria bem desafiador.
Mas a comunicação clássica
é, é claro, não apenas possível, mas bastante barata
nessas circunstâncias.
Agora, alguém poderia perguntar se é possível para Alice e Bob realizarem essa tarefa sem nem precisar do e-bit compartilhado.
Em outras palavras, existe
alguma forma de transmitir um qubit usando apenas
comunicação clássica?
A resposta é não; não é possível transmitir informação quântica usando apenas comunicação clássica, e isso não é tão difícil de provar
usando um pouco de teoria da informação quântica básica, que veremos na
terceira unidade da série.
Por ora, uma forma intuitiva
de pensar nisso é pensar no teorema da não clonagem.
Imagine que houvesse uma forma
de enviar informação quântica usando apenas comunicação clássica,
mas a comunicação clássica
pode ser facilmente copiada e transmitida, então isso significa
que a comunicação clássica
poderia ser transmitida para dois
receptores, Bob e Charlie, digamos.
Se ambos recebessem a
mesma informação clássica de Alice, ambos acabariam com Q?
Isso sugeriria que clonamos Q, mas sabemos que isso é impossível.
Como um aparte, vamos
observar que certamente é possível descrever
vetores de estado quântico usando informação clássica.
Cada vetor de estado quântico
que você verá na série está sendo descrito para você
usando informação clássica que foi transmitida para qualquer
dispositivo que você está assistindo.
Em geral, poderíamos imaginar
descrever qualquer estado em que Q esteja usando bits clássicos,
talvez com alguma precisão,
mas isso não é comunicação quântica; é apenas descrever
estados quânticos como vetores, e voltaremos à
distinção entre eles
em um instante.
Voltando ao cenário, no entanto, e trabalhando sob a
suposição de que Alice e Bob compartilham um e-bit, veremos que Alice e Bob
têm tudo o que precisam
para realizar a tarefa, e é isso que o protocolo de
teletransporte quântico faz, especificamente usando dois bits
de comunicação clássica.
Antes de entrar nesses
detalhes, no entanto, deixa eu fazer alguns comentários rápidos apenas para garantir que as suposições estejam claras.
Primeiro, estamos assumindo
aqui que o estado de Q é desconhecido para Alice e
Bob, então em particular,
Alice não pode enviar a Bob uma
descrição do estado Q porque ela geralmente não o conhece.
Também temos que considerar a possibilidade de que Q esteja correlacionado com outros sistemas, incluindo a possibilidade
de que esteja entrelaçado
com outros sistemas e a
transmissão deste qubit para Bob deve preservar essas correlações.
Por fim, mencionei
o teorema da não clonagem quando estava falando sobre
tentar comunicar qubits classicamente, mas
há outra conexão aqui
com o teorema da não clonagem, que é que, se Bob
recebe a transmissão deste qubit Q de Alice,
então ela não pode mais tê-lo,
porque Q não pode ser clonado, e isso é apenas algo a ter em mente
ao considerarmos o protocolo de teletransporte.
O protocolo de teletransporte
pode ser descrito de forma bastante simples e direta com o diagrama de circuit quântico, como você pode ver aqui.
É levemente estilizado no
sentido de que mostra a separação entre a parte de Alice e a parte de Bob, mas fora isso, é apenas
um diagrama de circuit quântico,
tudo acima da linha pontilhada
representa as ações de Alice e tudo abaixo
representa as ações de Bob.
O tempo vai da esquerda para a direita como sempre, e vemos que começamos
com esses dois qubits aqui estando no estado Phi plus,
então este é o e-bit
com que Alice e Bob começam.
Podemos colocar rótulos nos qubits para deixar claro qual é qual:
este é o qubit A, e este é o qubit
B que formam o e-bit,
e este é o qubit Q que
Alice deseja transmitir para Bob.
Aqui estamos hipotizando que
o estado deste qubit Q é Psi, mas um pouco mais tarde vamos considerar a possibilidade
de que Q esteja entrelaçado
com algum outro sistema. E o que o diagrama está afirmando, porque escrevemos psi aqui,
é que este circuit
efetivamente transmite qualquer estado psi que tínhamos
aqui na parte de Alice para cá, na parte de Bob;
a única comunicação
que temos cruzando a
linha entre Alice e Bob são os dois bits clássicos
representados por estas linhas duplas aqui.
Vamos diminuir um pouco este
diagrama para termos um pouco mais de espaço e examinar o
circuit mais de perto.
Já descrevi
as condições iniciais, mas apenas para recapitular: Alice tem um qubit A
e Bob tem um qubit B,
onde A e B juntos
estão no estado Phi plus, então é isso que significa compartilhar um e-bit.
Alice também tem este qubit Q que ela deseja transmitir para Bob, e estamos considerando o caso em que Q está em algum estado quântico arbitrário Psi.
Agora, não sabemos nada
sobre como Alice e Bob entraram na posse deste e-bit.
Pode ser que eles
o tenham há muito tempo; talvez tenham criado ele algum tempo atrás quando estavam no mesmo local
e têm o guardado
para esta ocasião, mas esses detalhes não são relevantes aqui.
Os próximos passos, que representam o
próprio protocolo de teletransporte, são os seguintes, e só para deixar claro,
esses são os passos que
o diagrama descreve e vamos apenas
escrevê-los em palavras para que fique claro o que
o diagrama expressa.
Alice primeiro realiza uma
operação CNOT onde o qubit Q que
ela quer enviar para Bob é o controle e o
qubit A é o alvo.
O próximo passo é que ela
realiza uma operação Hadamard em Q, e então mede
os dois qubits que ela tem,
A e Q com relação a
medições de base padrão e deixamos a minúscula a ser o resultado da medição do qubit A,
e deixamos a minúscula b ser o resultado da medição do qubit Q.
Alice então envia esses
dois bits clássicos para Bob, e esta é a única comunicação envolvida neste protocolo, e isso está indicado no diagrama
pelo fato de que esses dois
bits cruzam a linha pontilhada entre Alice e Bob,
que você pode pensar como representando qualquer
distância que os separa.
Depois que Bob recebe os bits
a e b, ele faz duas coisas.
Primeiro, se a é igual a um, então ele realiza uma operação X
ou, em outras palavras, um NOT gate no seu qubit B,
e caso contrário, se a é igual a zero, então ele não faz isso.
E da mesma forma,
se b é igual a um, então Bob realiza uma operação Z
ou um Z-gate ou uma inversão de fase
também no qubit b, e como
antes, se b é igual a zero, então ele não faz isso.
Tudo isso está indicado na figura onde temos esses controlled-X
e controlled-Z gates onde os controles são
os dois bits clássicos.
Você não precisa pensar nesses gates como sendo gates de controle
se não quiser; esta é apenas uma forma prática
de expressar o que queremos
na forma de um diagrama de circuit. O ponto é que Bob aplica
um X-gate ao qubit b se a é igual a um e
então ele aplica um Z-gate
ao qubit b se B é igual a um.
E por conveniência, mais tarde podemos escrever explicitamente
a operação combinada que Bob realiza no seu qubit b,
dependendo dos bits clássicos
que Alice envia.
Então esse é o protocolo de teletransporte; é bem simples, na verdade. O fato de que ele realmente funciona é outra questão,
e embora a análise
não seja tão complicada,
você não deve se sentir que está perdendo algo se não vir imediatamente por que funciona.
É por isso que precisamos
fazer uma análise e é isso que faremos a seguir.
Para analisar o protocolo de teletransporte, vamos trabalhar passo a passo para ver quais são os estados
dos três qubits em diferentes momentos.
Vamos primeiro considerar
o caso em que o qubit do topo está no estado AlphaZero mais beta um, onde alpha e beta
são quaisquer números complexos
que fazem com que este vetor
seja um vetor unitário.
Este é o qubit Q que
Alice está tentando transmitir, mas não nos importa muito
como ele é chamado neste momento.
Um pouco mais tarde, vamos
dar uma olhada na situação em que este qubit está
entrelaçado com outro sistema, mas este é um bom ponto de
partida para manter as coisas simples
e ver como a análise
funciona um pouco mais claramente.
Se considerarmos o estado dos
três qubits juntos aqui no início, vemos
que este estado tem a forma que você vê aqui.
Os dois primeiros qubits estão
no estado Phi plus, o terceiro qubit é o do topo
de acordo com a convenção
de ordenação de qubits que
descrevi na aula anterior, e então tomamos o produto tensorial para obter o estado dos
três qubits juntos.
Podemos expandir esta expressão
substituindo primeiro a definição do estado Phi plus e depois calculando o produto tensorial
e obtemos o estado
que você vê aqui.
Nem sempre é a melhor
estratégia, aliás, expandir completamente
um vetor como este; geralmente é uma boa ideia esperar até
você ter uma boa razão para fazer isso.
Mas aqui temos uma razão, que é que gostaríamos
de calcular a ação deste CNOT gate e, ao escrever o estado nesta forma,
podemos fazer isso muito facilmente.
E em particular, este é
o estado dos três qubits após o CNOT gate ser aplicado.
O terceiro qubit é o qubit de controle porque é o
que está no topo por nossa convenção, e o segundo qubit,
que é o do meio,
é o alvo, então apenas
operamos nos kets adequadamente: se o terceiro bit é
zero, nada acontece,
e se o terceiro bit é um,
então invertemos o segundo bit.
Em seguida, realizamos o Hadamard
gate no terceiro qubit; podemos escrever o vetor resultante como você pode ver
aqui, substituindo os
estados plus e minus pelos estados zero e um.
E se quisermos ter espaço suficiente
para expandir este, precisaremos diminuí-lo um pouco e agora, substituindo os estados
plus e minus
por suas definições,
trazendo a raiz quadrada de dois para o denominador, obtemos o estado que você vê aqui.
E ao expandir esse, obtemos o estado que você vê aqui.
Então, esse é o estado dos três qubits após Alice realizar suas duas operações.
Alice então mede
e se quisermos analisar as medições, o que fazemos é isolar os vetores de base padrão
para os sistemas sendo medidos
assim como falamos na aula dois, e se fizermos isso neste caso em particular, isto é o que obtemos.
E se você olhar para essa
expressão por um momento, pode parecer um pouco peculiar porque agora parece que o primeiro qubit,
que é o qubit de baixo,
de alguma forma depende de alpha e beta, mesmo que
neste ponto não tenha havido nenhuma comunicação através da linha pontilhada,
mas isso é apenas uma ilusão. Lembre-se de que escalares fluem
livremente através de produtos tensoriais, então não há realmente nenhum sentido
em que alpha e beta
estejam associados ao primeiro qubit.
O que realmente fizemos
aqui foi usar parênteses de acordo com a
multilinearidade dos produtos tensoriais.
De qualquer forma, essa é a forma que precisamos para ver o que a medição faz, e podemos ver uma
coisa interessante imediatamente
e é que as probabilidades dos quatro possíveis resultados de medição são sempre uniformes.
A probabilidade de medir cada
par de resultados de medição é um quarto, então, em particular,
não há nenhuma dependência
de alpha e beta.
Podemos ver isso em cada caso calculando a norma euclidiana ao quadrado de
qualquer vetor que está em produto tensorial com o vetor de base padrão que isolamos,
e em cada caso temos um quarto, que obtemos elevando ao quadrado um meio multiplicado pelo valor absoluto ao quadrado de alpha
mais o valor absoluto
ao quadrado de beta, que é um, e assim obtemos um quarto em cada caso.
É bastante importante, de fato,
que as probabilidades desses diferentes resultados não dependam de forma alguma do qubit que
Alice quer transmitir.
Não poderíamos ter que um estado arbitrário entra aqui e sai lá e ainda assim uma medição revelasse
informação sobre esse estado.
Se você quiser obter informação sobre um estado quântico arbitrário, vai precisar perturbar
esse estado em geral.
Aqui está uma tabela que descreve não apenas as probabilidades
dos diferentes resultados, mas também o estado dos
três qubits juntos
condicionado a cada possível
resultado de medição.
Obtemos isso normalizando os vetores em produto tensorial com os diferentes
estados de base padrão, mas isso é fácil neste caso,
simplesmente eliminamos o fator de um meio para obter um vetor unitário.
Então, o que temos imediatamente
após Alice medir é que Alice tem dois bits
aleatórios uniformes e só.
Em particular, ela não tem mais
o estado original e não tem nenhuma
informação sobre ele; ela tem apenas bits aleatórios.
O estado de Bob agora
depende de alpha e beta, bem como dos resultados das medições.
Se imaginarmos momentaneamente
que Alice ainda não enviou os resultados das medições
para que Bob não saiba quais são,
então ele não seria capaz
de obter nenhuma informação sobre alpha e beta
medindo seu qubit.
Essas quatro possibilidades
que temos aqui estão suficientemente embaralhadas para garantir que nenhuma informação
sobre alpha e beta
jamais pudesse ser obtida
por meio de uma medição. Isso tem que ser verdade em nível intuitivo porque do contrário teríamos
comunicação mais rápida que a luz.
Alice certamente não pode
transmitir informação a Bob sem enviar nada, mas é claro que Alice envia os resultados das medições
a Bob, então vamos expandir a tabela para ver o que acontece quando
Bob realiza suas operações.
Nesta coluna aqui, temos as diferentes operações que Bob efetivamente realiza para cada um dos possíveis
resultados das medições
como observamos antes,
e se formos um a um e aplicarmos essa
operação ao qubit de Bob, que é o primeiro, B,
vemos que obtemos o mesmo
resultado em todos os quatro casos, e esse resultado é o estado original.
Então, o estado original do qubit Q foi teletransportado com sucesso para B.
Se Bob quiser renomear seu qubit e chamá-lo de Q neste ponto, ele certamente pode, mas o ponto é que agora
ele tem o estado original
que Alice tinha e, claro, por necessidade, Alice não o tem mais.
Note também que o e-bit
foi efetivamente consumido neste processo;
o teletransporte tem um custo
e o custo é um e-bit e dois bits clássicos de comunicação, e quando o protocolo
termina, o e-bit se foi.
Estabelecemos agora que
o protocolo de teletransporte funciona corretamente sob a suposição de que o qubit do topo está em um estado quântico
da forma alpha vezes ket
zero mais beta vezes ket um.
Mas o que acontece se o
qubit do topo estiver entrelaçado com algum outro sistema, como
um dos nossos qubits adicionais
como temos aqui na tela? Podemos querer usar o teletransporte
nessas circunstâncias.
Talvez Alice e Bob realmente
planejem realizar o teletransporte 100 vezes para que Alice possa transmitir
algum registrador quântico de 100 qubits
para Bob, um qubit de cada vez.
Ou talvez esses qubits adicionais
nem estejam na posse de Alice
e outra pessoa os tenha; talvez Alice nem
saiba que eles existem.
A questão é: o teletransporte
ainda funciona mesmo que o qubit sendo teletransportado esteja entrelaçado com outro sistema?
Aqui, o estado do qubit Q junto com o sistema adicional
que estamos considerando é expresso como você pode ver lá em cima
onde gamma zero e
gamma um são vetores unitários representando estados quânticos
desse sistema adicional.
Sempre podemos escrever um estado arbitrário do sistema combinado dessa forma.
Na verdade, nem precisamos
de alpha e beta aqui, mas se os incluirmos,
então podemos tomar gamma zero e gamma um como vetores unitários
e isso tornará a
conexão com o caso mais simples que já consideramos mais transparente.
Podemos fazer uma
análise similar à que já fizemos, mas onde também acompanhamos
esse sistema adicional.
É um pouco mais confuso porque temos o sistema adicional, mas
a ideia é exatamente a mesma; aqui está um resumo muito rápido.
Este é o estado inicial; aqui está o estado após
o CNOT gate,
e aqui está o estado após
a operação Hadamard.
Se expandirmos essas coisas,
podemos expressar esse estado como você pode ver aqui,
esse é o estado imediatamente
antes das medições de Alice, e se formos pelas
possibilidades assim como antes
e considerarmos o que
acontece quando Bob aplica qualquer operação que ele deve aplicar,
então descobrimos que de fato
o estado correto sai e o protocolo funciona como esperado.
Nesta tabela, aliás, estamos usando a letra R para
referir a esse sistema adicional, e você pode ver que estamos
usando um truque bastante simples,
que é decidir que preferiríamos, pelo menos momentaneamente, ordenar
os sistemas como B, R, A, Q
porque isso é mais conveniente para escrever os estados aqui.
De acordo com o diagrama, os sistemas devem ser
ordenados como B, A, Q, R,
mas desde que deixemos claro, podemos escolher uma
ordenação diferente que seja mais conveniente.
Em suma, tudo que está acontecendo nesta análise é o
mesmo que aconteceu na análise mais simples,
mas por acaso temos
esses vetores adicionais, gamma zero e gamma um,
que basicamente vêm junto de carona.
Sempre temos gamma zero
quando há um fator de alpha e gamma um quando
há um fator de beta e no final,
tudo funciona corretamente.
Isso não é de forma alguma surpreendente; temos um processo físico que age como a operação identidade em um qubit
em um estado quântico arbitrário, e há apenas uma
forma isso pode acontecer e é que a operação
é a operação identidade.
Isso é um pouco mais fácil de explicar usando a formulação geral
da informação quântica, mas o ponto é que, pela linearidade,
realmente não precisávamos fazer essa análise adicional.
Uma vez que sabemos que
o teletransporte funciona corretamente para um único qubit isolado, podemos concluir que há
apenas uma coisa possível
que pode descrever o que o protocolo faz, e é que ele implementa
a operação identidade onde um qubit entra aqui
e sai aqui, agindo efetivamente como um canal quântico
perfeito sem ruído.
Apenas alguns comentários rápidos
sobre o teletransporte antes de passar para o
segundo exemplo da aula, que é a codificação superdensa.
Primeiro, acho importante esclarecer que o teletransporte não é uma aplicação da informação quântica; é um protocolo
e especificamente é um
protocolo para realizar comunicação quântica.
Para que o teletransporte,
como o descrevi, seja útil, tem que haver alguma razão para realizar comunicação quântica.
Segundo, é razoável especular que o teletransporte poderia, um
dia, se tornar uma forma padrão
de comunicar informação quântica, e especificamente um processo conhecido como destilação de entrelaçamento
poderia potencialmente ser usado
como forma de comunicar qubits de forma confiável. Se Alice e Bob souberem que vão comunicar informação quântica ou tiverem necessidade de comunicar
informação quântica, então este processo de destilação de entrelaçamento
poderia ser usado para converter um número maior de e-bits ruidosos
em um número menor
de e-bits de alta qualidade que poderiam então ser usados para teletransporte sem ruído ou quase sem ruído.
A ideia é que o processo
de destilação de entrelaçamento não é tão delicado em certo sentido; poderíamos aceitar perdas e
se não der certo,
então poderíamos simplesmente tentar novamente, ao passo que os qubits reais que
gostaríamos de comunicar poderiam ser considerados muito mais preciosos.
Claro, tudo isso é especulação, mas o ponto é que não é difícil hipotizar situações
em que o teletransporte
poderia ser uma forma muito prática
de comunicar qubits.
E o ponto final
sobre o teletransporte é que a ideia por trás do teletransporte e a forma como ele funciona
é bastante fundamental
na informação e computação quântica; o teletransporte é realmente uma pedra angular da teoria da informação quântica e variações
sobre a ideia também surgem
frequentemente; é apenas um exemplo: há propostas para
implementar diferentes quantum gates
usando teletransporte, mas
onde diferentes estados iniciais e medições são
escolhidos para que o resultado
seja aplicar uma operação escolhida
em vez de comunicar.
O próximo exemplo é a codificação superdensa.
Assim como o teletransporte quântico,
a codificação superdensa é um protocolo e o que ela realiza é complementar ao teletransporte.
Enquanto o teletransporte permite
que um qubit seja transmitido usando um e-bit e dois
bits clássicos de comunicação,
a codificação superdensa permite
que dois bits clássicos sejam transmitidos usando
um e-bit e um qubit de comunicação quântica.
Então, em suma, a codificação superdensa permite a transmissão
de informação clássica e o motivo pelo qual é
chamada de codificação superdensa
é que ela permite que dois
bits clássicos de comunicação sejam comprimidos em um único qubit,
mas precisamos consumir um
e-bit para realizar isso.
Aqui está uma explicação mais precisa
da configuração.
Mais uma vez, temos Alice e Bob, onde Alice é a remetente
e Bob é o receptor, e desta vez Alice tem dois bits clássicos
que ela quer enviar para Bob.
Alice é capaz de enviar a Bob um único qubit, e Alice e Bob compartilham
um e-bit que podem usar para ajudá-los a realizar sua tarefa,
que é para Bob receber
os dois bits clássicos.
Agora, há um sentido em que essa tarefa pode parecer menos interessante do que a tarefa que
o teletransporte realiza,
particularmente se considerarmos
que enviar qubits é significativamente mais
difícil ou mais desafiador do que enviar bits clássicos,
o que é um ponto de vista bastante razoável, mas é definitivamente interessante que seja possível fazer isso.
Uma razão pela qual é interessante
é que, na verdade, é impossível realizar
essa tarefa de transmitir dois bits clássicos de informação
usando um único qubit sem
usar o e-bit.
Sabemos disso por causa de um famoso teorema conhecido como teorema de Holevo.
O teorema de Holevo é
mais geral do que isso, e o enunciado preciso
do teorema de Holevo é um pouco técnico e requer alguma explicação,
mas uma implicação dele
é que você não pode transmitir qualquer número de bits clássicos de comunicação usando menos qubits de
comunicação quântica sozinha.
Se você quiser transmitir de forma confiável dois bits clássicos de
informação usando qubits e não tiver
um e-bit para usar,
vai precisar enviar dois qubits, então eles podem muito bem armazenar os bits que você quer transmitir.
Outra razão pela qual a codificação superdensa
é interessante é por causa do estreito relacionamento complementar que tem com o teletransporte, e
voltaremos a isso
um pouco mais tarde. Aqui está uma descrição em circuit quântico do protocolo de codificação superdensa.
Para este, não vou
listar todos os passos, mas em vez disso vamos ficar com a descrição do diagrama de circuit.
Como você pode ver, novamente
temos Alice e Bob, onde Alice está no topo
e Bob está na parte inferior.
Aqui está o e-bit que está
inicialmente compartilhado entre Alice e Bob, que de alguma forma foi estabelecido antes que o protocolo fosse executado.
Alice tem dois bits clássicos, A e B, que você pode ver aqui
e, por meio do protocolo que o circuit descreve,
esses dois bits clássicos
vão acabar nas mãos de Bob.
Há apenas um qubit
que cruza a linha entre Alice e Bob, e claro não há
nenhum bit clássico sendo enviado,
é a transmissão dos
dois bits clássicos que é o objetivo do protocolo.
Você também notará que ele tem
exatamente os mesmos componentes usados no teletransporte; temos um CNOT
gate, um Hadamard gate,
e um Z-gate e um X-gate
controlados por bits clássicos.
Eles estão dispostos de forma diferente, no entanto, então vamos passar para a
análise para ver como funciona.
Para analisar como a codificação superdensa funciona, vamos começar escrevendo
a base de Bell, que está muito no
coração da análise.
O que vamos fazer é
primeiro dar uma olhada no efeito que as ações de Alice
têm no estado Phi plus, e o que veremos é
que Alice transforma este
estado Phi plus em um
dos quatro estados de Bell, dependendo dos bits
que ela quer enviar.
Então, vamos escrever uma tabela para que possamos acompanhar
o que está acontecendo.
Primeiro, se A e B são ambos zero, então nem o Z-gate nem
o X-gate é aplicado, então as ações de Alice não fazem nada,
o que quer dizer que Phi
plus é mapeado para Phi plus.
Também podemos expressar isso como uma equação como você vê aqui:
nada acontece com o qubit de Alice e nada acontece com o qubit de Bob
e não fazer nada é representado
pela matriz identidade.
Agora, o que acontece se A é igual a zero e B é igual a um?
Bem, como B é igual a um, aplicamos o Z-gate e
não aplicamos o X-gate porque A é igual a zero
e vemos que o efeito geral é que Alice realiza um Z-gate.
Alice está à direita
porque ela está no topo, embora não
faria na verdade nenhuma diferença neste caso
específico; o efeito é que
o estado Phi plus é
transformado em Phi minus, o que você pode visualizar
a partir dessas expressões, se você se lembrar como um Z-gate funciona.
Então, podemos adicionar este à nossa tabela; há mais dois casos a percorrer: se A é igual a um
e B é igual a zero,
então Alice realiza um
X-gate que transforma Phi plus em Chi plus, e se A é igual a um
e B é igual a um,
então Alice realiza Z e depois
X e obtemos Chi minus.
Então, nossa tabela nos diz o que acontece nos quatro casos possíveis e é que Alice efetivamente escolhe qual
dos quatro estados de Bell ela
gostaria de compartilhar com Bob, e ela tem a liberdade de escolher agindo apenas no seu qubit
e isso é um aspecto bastante interessante do entrelaçamento.
Alice então envia seu qubit
para Bob; neste ponto, Bob tem um dos quatro estados de Bell e apenas precisa
descobrir qual é
para recuperar os bits.
E podemos verificar que
de fato um CNOT gate seguido de um Hadamard gate
como temos no diagrama faz a coisa certa.
Não vou passar por eles em detalhe, mas se você escolher fazer isso, verá que o efeito é
como você vê aqui na tabela.
Uma forma de verificar isso
é simplesmente calcular. Alternativamente, podemos reconhecer que já
passamos por isso ao contrário
na aula anterior. Na aula anterior, tínhamos o Hadamard gate primeiro e o CNOT gate depois
e vimos que esse circuit
mapeava estados de base padrão para estados de Bell com um incômodo
sinal de menos em um dos casos.
Quando invertemos a ordem dos gates e consideramos o fato
de que ambos esses dois gates são seus próprios inversos,
o que obtemos é o inverso,
e então o que temos neste
caso é que a ação vai na direção oposta
e o sinal de menos pode escolher em qual
lado quer estar,
mas caso contrário, está onde deve estar, e neste ponto é
imediato que a medição revela os valores corretos,
o sinal de menos aqui não nos incomoda porque um aparece com
probabilidade um neste caso, e é tudo que há na análise.
Em suma, Alice escolhe um estado de Bell e Bob descobre qual é.
Apenas alguns breves comentários
sobre a codificação superdensa antes de prosseguirmos; primeiro, devemos reconhecer que a codificação superdensa
provavelmente não é provável
de ser útil ou prática de nenhuma forma como meio de
transmitir informação clássica.
A comunicação clássica
é muito barata e enviar qubits fisicamente é desafiador, para dizer o mínimo,
e enquanto esse for o caso, não esperaríamos nenhuma
vantagem prática alguma da codificação superdensa.
Mas só porque provavelmente não é
prática não significa que a codificação superdensa não é interessante.
É muito interessante, de fato; por um lado, a ideia subjacente é
realmente bastante fundamental,
e quando me refiro à ideia subjacente, quero dizer a ideia de que, se Alice
compartilha um estado de Bell com Bob,
então ela pode escolher transformar esse estado para qualquer outro estado de Bell que
ela escolher sozinha; ela não precisa da
ajuda de Bob para fazer isso.
Este é um exemplo específico
que diz respeito aos estados de Bell, mas há uma ideia subjacente mais geral que diz respeito à liberdade que um jogador
tem de transformar um estado entrelaçado compartilhado com outro jogador, e entender exatamente
qual é essa liberdade
é um passo importante na compreensão da informação quântica e veremos exatamente como descrever essa liberdade em termos simples
e elegantes na
terceira unidade da série.
A codificação superdensa também
fornece um exemplo concreto do que você pode fazer com o entrelaçamento, que é permitir que dois bits clássicos sejam transmitidos
enviando um único qubit. Como já mencionei, isso é provavelmente impossível pelo teorema de Holevo sem entrelaçamento.
Também podemos considerar o teletransporte e a codificação superdensa juntos, e vemos que eles
estabelecem uma equivalência
entre um qubit de comunicação quântica e dois bits de comunicação clássica.
Contanto que esteja disposto
a gastar um e-bit, você pode efetivamente
converter um no outro.
O teletransporte permite a
comunicação de um qubit usando dois bits clássicos de comunicação e a codificação superdensa vai no outro sentido
e permite dois bits clássicos
de comunicação usando um qubit de comunicação quântica.
Sem gastar o e-bit, no entanto, você não pode transformar
um no outro; é o entrelaçamento que
torna isso possível.
O terceiro e último exemplo
que vamos cobrir nesta aula não é um protocolo, mas sim um
jogo conhecido como o jogo CHSH.
Quando falamos sobre um jogo neste contexto, não estamos falando sobre algo que é para ser
jogado por diversão ou esporte,
mas sim sobre uma abstração matemática no sentido da teoria dos jogos, por exemplo.
Abstrações matemáticas de jogos são muito comumente estudadas em
economia e ciência da computação, por exemplo, e há
bastante valor
a ser encontrado na abstração, então os jogos não são todos diversão
nos jogos, como se descobre,
embora seja divertido pensar sobre eles.
Neste caso específico, o que temos é essencialmente
um experimento mental que pode ser descrito de uma
forma bastante intuitiva como um jogo.
As letras CHSH referem-se aos autores, John Clauser, Michael
Horne, Abner Shimony e Richard Holt, de um artigo de 1969
onde o exemplo
foi descrito pela primeira vez. Eles não o descreveram
como um jogo, de fato, e é bastante comum
referir-se a este exemplo
não como o jogo CHSH, mas
sim como a desigualdade CHSH.
Para um cientista da computação como eu, no entanto, é muito natural
descrevê-lo como um jogo.
Já sugeri que
abstrações matemáticas de jogos são importantes e úteis e há muitas categorias diferentes de jogos
que podem ser consideradas. O jogo CHSH é um
exemplo de uma classe de jogos chamados jogos não locais.
Aqui está a configuração em geral
para um jogo não local.
Temos dois jogadores, Alice e Bob, que cooperam como equipe, então eles ganham juntos
ou perdem juntos.
Isso significa que eles não têm
incentivo para agir egoistamente, então é essencialmente o extremo oposto dos jogos de soma zero,
que são puramente competitivos; aqui o jogo é puramente cooperativo.
Há uma terceira entidade chamada o árbitro.
O árbitro não é um jogador no jogo, mas sim o árbitro
conduz o jogo, e na verdade você pode pensar sobre a especificação
de uma instância particular
de um jogo não local e a especificação de um
árbitro como sendo equivalentes.
Há uma restrição crucialmente importante imposta a Alice e Bob, que é que uma vez que o jogo começa, eles têm proibido de
se comunicar entre si.
Eles podem concordar de antemão com
qualquer estratégia que escolherem, mas nenhuma comunicação
é permitida entre eles durante o jogo em si.
Se você quiser, pode imaginar
o jogo acontecendo em uma instalação segura de algum tipo, como se o árbitro estivesse desempenhando
o papel de um detetive
e Alice e Bob fossem suspeitos em
salas diferentes de uma delegacia de polícia, mas outra forma de
pensar sobre a configuração
é que Alice e Bob estão
separados por uma vasta distância e a comunicação é proibida porque a velocidade da luz
não permite comunicação
rápida o suficiente. Se Alice tentar enviar uma
mensagem a Bob, por exemplo, o jogo terá terminado até
Bob a receber.
A forma como um jogo não local
funciona é que primeiro, o árbitro faz a ambos
Alice e Bob uma pergunta.
A pergunta de Alice é rotulada X e a pergunta de Bob é rotulada Y.
Em geral, você pode pensar sobre X e Y como sendo estados clássicos
de quaisquer estados clássicos que você quiser e, no
caso específico do jogo CHSH,
X e Y são bits.
Alice e Bob devem então fornecer respostas; a resposta de Alice é rotulada A,
e a resposta de Bob é rotulada B,
e novamente, essas respostas podem ser vistas como estados clássicos em geral e, como as perguntas, elas
serão bits no jogo CHSH.
Neste ponto, o
árbitro toma uma decisão; Alice e Bob ganham ou perdem dependendo de se
o par de respostas A, B
é considerado correto para o
par de perguntas X, Y que o árbitro fez, e direi um pouco mais
sobre isso em um instante.
Primeiro, vamos dar uma olhada
mais detalhada no árbitro para entender o que é
que é potencialmente desafiador para Alice e Bob em um jogo não local.
E o que torna um jogo não local
potencialmente desafiador é que o árbitro pode usar aleatoriedade para escolher as perguntas X e Y.
Isso significa que Alice
e Bob têm incerteza; eles não sabem de antemão qual pergunta vão receber, e talvez mais importante,
eles não sabem qual pergunta
o outro recebeu, e é essa incerteza
junto com o fato de que eles não podem se comunicar
que apresenta o desafio.
Então, é similar à situação onde um detetive
interroga dois suspeitos em salas diferentes; se
os suspeitos não sabem
que perguntas o outro recebeu, é muito mais difícil, se forem culpados, manter a história consistente.
Agora, mencionei um pouco
atrás que o árbitro toma uma determinação
de que Alice e Bob responderam
corretamente ou incorretamente
dependendo das perguntas
que receberam.
Assume-se que essa
determinação é feita de acordo com alguma regra fixa e você pode considerar qualquer regra que quiser,
mas seja como for,
assume-se que Alice
e Bob conhecem a regra, então pelo menos têm uma chance
de responder corretamente.
Veremos a regra para o jogo CHSH em um momento, mas poderíamos
considerar uma regra diferente e teríamos um exemplo diferente
de um jogo não local.
Alguns jogos não locais são interessantes e, de fato, alguns são bastante fascinantes e misteriosos até hoje, e
alguns não são tão interessantes,
isso é apenas a natureza
do modelo de jogo não local.
De qualquer forma, essas são as duas coisas diferentes que são necessárias para descrever um árbitro: como exatamente as perguntas são escolhidas
e quais pares de respostas estão corretos para cada possível par de perguntas.
Se temos uma descrição
dessas duas coisas, então temos uma descrição para o árbitro e isso efetivamente descreve
uma instância de um jogo não local.
Agora vamos dar uma olhada no
jogo CHSH especificamente.
A forma como o jogo é
definido ou, equivalentemente, como o árbitro é definido é a seguinte:
primeiro, como já mencionei, as perguntas e respostas são todas bits, então o árbitro envia um bit X
a Alice e um bit Y a Bob,
e cada um responde com um bit. Alice responde com A
e Bob responde com B.
A forma como o árbitro escolhe
quais perguntas fazer é simples: ele as escolhe
uniformemente ao acaso,
portanto, o par de perguntas X, Y é igualmente provável de ser qualquer uma
das quatro possibilidades: zero, zero; zero, um;
um, zero; e um, um.
Por fim, a regra que
determina quais respostas vencem e quais perdem é
que um par de respostas A, B está correto para o par de perguntas X, Y
se e somente se o ou exclusivo de A e B é igual ao E lógico de X e Y.
Isso pode ser um pouco mais fácil de digerir se expressarmos essas condições
na forma de uma tabela como você vê aqui.
Na primeira coluna, temos os quatro possíveis pares de perguntas, e na segunda coluna temos as condições sobre A e B
que são necessárias para
Alice e Bob ganharem.
Nos primeiros três casos,
o E de A e Y é zero, então o ou exclusivo deve ser igual a zero
para eles ganharem,
e isso é a mesma coisa que dizer que A e B devem ser iguais, porque A e B são bits; no quarto caso,
o E de X e Y é igual
a um e então o ou exclusivo de A e B deve ser igual a um para que Alice e Bob ganhem
e isso é a mesma coisa
que dizer que A e B devem ser diferentes.
Então, esse é o jogo CHSH, e agora podemos pensar sobre
diferentes estratégias possíveis para Alice e Bob e como
eles podem se sair neste jogo.
Vamos começar pensando sobre
estratégias determinísticas onde a resposta A de Alice é uma
função da pergunta X que ela recebe, e
da mesma forma, a resposta B de Bob
é uma função da
pergunta Y que ele recebe.
E resulta que nenhuma
estratégia determinística pode possivelmente vencer sempre.
Uma forma de raciocinar isso é
simplesmente ir um a um por todas as estratégias determinísticas possíveis e verificar que cada uma delas perde
para pelo menos um dos quatro
possíveis pares de perguntas.
Alice e Bob têm, cada um,
quatro funções possíveis para escolher; vimos essas
quatro funções na aula um, então há 16 possibilidades
a verificar no geral.
Outra forma de ver isso é
pensar sobre as equações aqui na tela; estamos pensando
sobre estratégias determinísticas
onde A e B são funções
de X e Y respectivamente.
Então, por exemplo, A de zero
representa a resposta de Alice quando sua pergunta X é igual a zero, e A de um representa a resposta de Alice
quando sua pergunta X é igual a um.
Essas são as quatro equações
que devem ser verdadeiras para que as condições
de vitória sejam satisfeitas em cada um dos quatro casos.
Por exemplo, se X é igual a
zero e Y é igual a zero, então o ou exclusivo de A
e B deve ser igual a zero,
ao passo que no caso em que X é igual a um e Y é igual a um, o
ou exclusivo de A e B deve ser igual a um.
Uma forma de ver que
não há como escolher as funções A e B de modo que
essas equações sejam todas verdadeiras é simplesmente tomar o ou exclusivo
de todas as equações.
O ou exclusivo de qualquer
valor binário com ele mesmo é igual a zero, e então segue que o ou exclusivo
dos lados esquerdos
é igual a zero; isso é
porque temos duas instâncias de a zero, duas instâncias de a um,
duas instâncias de b zero
e duas instâncias de b um.
Então, ao aplicar o XOR em todos eles,
obtemos o resultado final de zero, mas se tomarmos o ou exclusivo dos lados direitos das equações,
obtemos um, não zero. Então as quatro equações
não podem ser todas verdadeiras; pelo menos uma delas tem que estar errada,
e isso levará a uma
derrota para Alice e Bob em pelo menos um dos quatro casos.
E então segue, porque o árbitro escolhe as perguntas
uniformemente, que a probabilidade de Alice e Bob ganharem
usando uma estratégia determinística
é no máximo três quartos ou 75%.
O fato de que Alice e Bob podem ganhar com probabilidade três quartos é bastante fácil de ver
na verdade; se Alice e Bob ambos respondem zero o tempo todo, por exemplo,
eles estarão corretos três
das quatro vezes.
Então Alice e Bob não podem
fazer melhor do que ganhar 75% do tempo usando uma
estratégia determinística.
Mas e uma estratégia probabilística?
Bem, acontece que usar
uma estratégia probabilística não pode ajudá-los de forma alguma, porque toda
estratégia probabilística
pode alternativamente ser vista
como uma seleção aleatória de uma estratégia determinística, assim como operações probabilísticas podem ser vistas
como seleções aleatórias de
operações determinísticas, como vimos na primeira aula.
A média nunca é
maior que o máximo, então segue que uma
estratégia probabilística não oferece nenhuma vantagem
em termos de ganho
sobre uma estratégia determinística. Isso inclui até mesmo a possibilidade de que as escolhas aleatórias de Alice e Bob sejam correlacionadas.
Então, a conclusão é que ganhar com probabilidade três quartos é o melhor que Alice
e Bob podem possivelmente fazer usando qualquer estratégia clássica,
seja determinística
ou probabilística.
A questão natural a fazer neste ponto é se Alice e Bob podem fazer melhor usando uma estratégia quântica,
e em particular
se eles compartilham um estado quântico entrelaçado que poderiam ter preparado
antes de jogar o jogo, isso pode ajudá-los?
A resposta é sim, pode, e esse é o ponto do exemplo e é por isso que é tão interessante.
Então vamos ver exatamente como
Alice e Bob podem se sair melhor neste jogo usando entrelaçamento.
A primeira coisa que precisamos fazer é definir um vetor de estado quântico Chi
theta para cada ângulo theta, como você pode ver aqui na tela.
Então, Chi theta é igual a
cosseno theta vezes ket zero mais seno theta vezes ket
um, e aqui, aliás,
estamos pensando sobre
ângulos em termos de radianos.
Então, por exemplo, aqui está o vetor que obtemos quando theta é igual a pi sobre
quatro, que é 45 graus.
O cosseno de pi sobre quatro
e o seno de pi sobre quatro são ambos iguais a um sobre
a raiz quadrada de dois, então este é apenas outro
nome para o estado plus.
Aqui está outro exemplo quando theta é igual a três vezes pi sobre oito, e caso você não
saiba de cabeça o seno
e o cosseno de três vezes pi sobre oito,
aqui está uma tabela dos senos e cossenos que vamos
realmente precisar
ao longo deste exemplo
e que inclui os que precisamos para este vetor em particular.
Agora, se quisermos tomar o produto interno entre dois quaisquer desses vetores
para ângulos, alpha e beta, digamos, é
simples fazer isso.
Temos apenas entradas de números reais
nesses vetores, então não há conjugados
complexos com que se preocupar e obtemos o produto dos cossenos
mais o produto dos senos, e podemos usar uma das
chamadas fórmulas de adição de ângulos
para simplificar isso; é o
cosseno da diferença entre os ângulos e
porque a função cosseno
é simétrica ao redor de zero,
na verdade não importa em que ordem os tomamos.
Se você não tiver esses tipos
de identidades trigonométricas decoradas,
aliás, você não está sozinho, mas não precisa lembrá-las,
você pode simplesmente consultá-las. Este aqui faz sentido
quando você pensa sobre a interpretação geométrica
do produto interno
entre vetores unitários reais como o cosseno do ângulo entre eles.
Se calcularmos o produto interno
do produto tensorial de quaisquer dois desses vetores
com o estado Phi plus, obtemos uma expressão de aparência similar
exceto que há uma raiz
de dois no denominador.
Esta é a primeira vez
que o estado Phi plus aparece no contexto
deste exemplo, aliás, e veremos exatamente por que estamos interessados
neste produto interno em particular em breve, mas por enquanto vamos
simplesmente observar que obtemos a mesma expressão que tínhamos
para o produto interno dividida
pela raiz quadrada de dois e então podemos simplificar como antes.
Em seguida, vamos definir uma
matriz unitária, U theta, para cada ângulo theta
como você vê aqui,
não é difícil
verificar que isso é de fato uma matriz unitária.
A coisa fundamental que precisamos
reconhecer é que o vetor si theta é ortogonal ao
vetor si theta mais pi sobre dois, e isso faz sentido
porque se rotacionarmos por pi sobre dois, que é 90 graus, obtemos
um vetor ortogonal.
Se então multiplicarmos U
theta por U theta dagger, obtemos a matriz identidade.
Falando intuitivamente,
o que essa matriz faz como operação é mapear si theta para ket zero e si theta mais pi dois para ket um.
Neste ponto, temos
tudo o que precisamos para descrever a estratégia de Alice e Bob.
Primeiro, assim como tínhamos para o teletransporte e a codificação superdensa, Alice e Bob começarão compartilhando um e-bit.
Alice tem um qubit A,
Bob tem um qubit B, e juntos os dois qubits
estão no estado Phi plus.
As ações de Alice são as seguintes: ela olha para o bit X que
ela recebe do árbitro,
e se X é igual a zero,
ela realiza U zero em A, que por acaso é a
mesma coisa que não fazer nada porque U zero é a matriz identidade,
e se X é igual a um, por outro lado, ela aplica U pi sobre quatro em A.
Depois de aplicar uma
das duas operações, ela mede A usando uma
medição de base padrão e envia qualquer resultado
que obtiver ao árbitro.
Bob faz algo muito similar; seu qubit é chamado B, é claro, e ele recebe Y do
árbitro em vez de X
mas a diferença fundamental é
que ele usa ângulos diferentes para suas operações unitárias.
Se Y é igual a zero, ele
aplica U pi sobre oito, e se Y é igual a um, ele aplica U menos pi sobre oito.
E veremos por que essas escolhas de ângulos são boas escolhas em breve;
não é de forma alguma óbvio.
E aqui está um diagrama de circuit
que expressa esta estratégia.
Bob está no topo e Alice
está na parte inferior desta vez; aqui está o e-bit que está entrando
e esses são os gates unitários
que Alice e Bob podem ou não aplicar
dependendo do que X e Y são.
Para este e este aqui, temos gates que estão sendo controlados pelo bit X ou pelo bit Y
e para esses dois aqui, temos o que parecem
gates de controle, exceto que o círculo não está preenchido.
E o que isso significa é
que, se o bit de controle está definido como zero, então o gate é realizado e, se o controle está definido como
um, então nada acontece.
Então, é como um
gate de controle comum exceto que os papéis de zero e um para o controle estão trocados.
Então, efetivamente, Bob
realiza este gate aqui se Y é igual a zero, ele
realiza este gate aqui
se Y é igual a um, e da mesma forma, Alice realiza este gate aqui
se X é igual a zero, e este gate aqui,
se X é igual a um.
Então, essa é a estratégia de Alice e Bob e agora precisamos apenas
descobrir quão bem ela funciona.
Para a análise da estratégia quântica que acabei de descrever, realmente precisamos apenas de duas coisas neste ponto: primeiro, a
matriz unitária U Theta
é como você vê aqui, e
segundo, tínhamos esta fórmula.
Na verdade, nem precisamos mais da definição do vetor si theta; essas duas equações são tudo de que precisamos.
Há quatro casos a
considerar, começando com o caso um, que é X igual
a zero e Y igual a zero.
E se olharmos de volta para a estratégia, veremos que neste
caso Alice realiza U zero no seu qubit e Bob realiza
U pi sobre oito no seu qubit.
Lembre-se, Alice está na
parte inferior e Bob está no topo, então o estado que eles
obtêm parece assim.
E ao expandir isso
de acordo com a definição de U theta, obtemos esta
expressão que você vê aqui.
Não precisamos expandir
isso mais porque temos a outra
fórmula para nos ajudar.
E se aplicarmos essa fórmula
para cada um dos quatro termos, obtemos isso.
Neste ponto, Alice e Bob ambos medem e aqui está uma tabela que
explica a distribuição dos resultados.
Tomamos o valor absoluto
ao quadrado dos coeficientes para obter as probabilidades, que por acaso são os
quadrados dos coeficientes
porque os coeficientes são
todos números reais neste caso.
Se usarmos os
valores de seno e cosseno do início da aula
junto com algumas simetrias, podemos expressar essas probabilidades
como temos aqui
na última coluna.
Agora, o que realmente nos importa
é a probabilidade de eles ganharem, e lembre-se que, no caso em que X e Y são ambos zero,
eles ganham se A e B são iguais e perdem se A e B não são iguais.
Se calcularmos essas probabilidades, veremos que a probabilidade
de que A e B sejam iguais é a soma deste número e deste número,
que é igual a dois mais
raiz de dois, tudo sobre quatro, que é cerca de 85%.
A probabilidade de que A e B não sejam iguais é dois menos raiz de dois, tudo sobre quatro, que é naturalmente um menos a quantidade
que acabamos de calcular, então
eles ganham com probabilidade de cerca de 85% neste caso.
Há mais três casos a considerar, mas todos são muito similares a este,
no caso em que X é igual
a zero e Y é igual a um, Bob aplica U menos pi sobre oito em vez de U pi sobre oito,
os valores nas
fórmulas mudam um pouco, mas acabamos com exatamente
as mesmas probabilidades que tínhamos no caso anterior.
Quando X é igual a zero e Y é igual a um, Alice e Bob ainda ganham
quando A e B são iguais e então temos exatamente a mesma probabilidade de ganho
de antes.
No terceiro caso, quando X é igual a um e Y é igual a zero, temos uma situação similar; os ângulos são diferentes,
mas têm exatamente
o mesmo relacionamento entre
si, e de fato, obtemos exatamente o
mesmo vetor que obtivemos no caso anterior.
Então as probabilidades são as mesmas e também é a probabilidade de ganho.
O último caso é um pouco
diferente, como poderíamos esperar, porque a condição de ganho
é diferente neste caso.
Quando X e Y são ambos iguais a um, Alice e Bob ganham quando
A e B são diferentes.
O método básico é o mesmo, embora os ângulos sejam diferentes; desta vez, obtemos este vetor aqui
e você pode verificar isso passando pelas subtrações necessárias.
As probabilidades mudam finalmente, e se consultarmos os valores que precisamos, vemos que as probabilidades
efetivamente
trocaram de posição antes, então desta vez é a probabilidade
de que A não seja igual a B que é a maior das duas,
mas isso é bom porque neste caso, Alice e Bob ganham quando
A e B não são iguais.
Então mais uma vez, eles ganham com
probabilidade de aproximadamente 85%.
Dado que eles ganham em todos os
casos com a mesma probabilidade, que é dois mais raiz de dois
tudo sobre quatro ou cerca de 85%,
essa é a probabilidade
de eles ganharem no geral.
Isso é melhor do que qualquer estratégia clássica pode fazer para este jogo, e é isso
que o torna interessante.
Esta é, por acaso, a
probabilidade de ganho ótima para qualquer estratégia quântica; você
não pode fazer melhor do que isso usando qualquer estado entrelaçado.
Esse fato é conhecido como desigualdade de Tsirelson; tem o nome de Boris
Tsirelson que primeiro o provou, e tanto quanto sei foi
uma das primeiras pessoas
a descrever este exemplo como um jogo. Caso a análise
que acabamos de passar pareça um pouco misteriosa,
é possível pensar
sobre ela geometricamente, o que pode ser útil para
te dar uma melhor noção da escolha dos ângulos.
Especificamente, se usarmos a
fórmula que você vê aqui, que podemos facilmente deduzir
das expressões
que já encontramos para os
produtos internos envolvidos, então podemos alternativamente
expressar as probabilidades dos diferentes possíveis
resultados de medição
nos quatro casos da seguinte forma: primeiro, se X, Y é igual a zero, zero, então estas são as probabilidades
dos vários resultados de medição, e você tem que rever ou voltar para a análise
que acabamos de fazer para concluir isso usando nossa fórmula.
Aqui, podemos ver os
diferentes vetores de estado desenhados como eram antes, e a codificação de cores aqui
é que o azul corresponde
ao resultado zero e o vermelho
corresponde ao resultado um.
Você pode ver que o ângulo
entre os vetores azuis e o ângulo entre os
vetores vermelhos é relativamente pequeno,
é pi sobre oito em ambos os casos, então o cosseno é relativamente grande, e isso significa que a
probabilidade de os dois resultados
serem iguais é relativamente grande.
No caso em que X, Y é igual a zero, um, é uma situação similar; o
ângulo entre os vetores da mesma cor é pequeno,
então a probabilidade de
resultados iguais é, novamente, relativamente grande.
O terceiro caso é similar, e no quarto caso
quando X, Y é igual a um, um, algo interessante acontece;
desta vez, apenas pela forma como,
esses vetores foram escolhidos, vemos que os ângulos entre
vetores da mesma cor
são relativamente grandes, e especificamente os ângulos são três vezes
pi sobre oito em ambos os casos.
Isso significa que a probabilidade
de que os resultados de medição sejam iguais é relativamente pequena, mas este é o único caso
no qual Alice e Bob ganham
quando suas respostas discordam,
então é o que queremos.
Mais uma vez, aqui estão os vetores: quando X, Y é igual a zero, zero,
quando X, Y é igual a zero, um,
quando X, Y é igual a um, zero,
e quando X, Y é igual a um, um.
E talvez esta imagem geométrica
seja útil para construir alguma intuição
sobre como essa estratégia funciona
e por que esses vários ângulos foram escolhidos da forma que foram.
Para encerrar a aula, farei alguns breves
comentários sobre o jogo CHSH.
Primeiro, como já mencionei, este exemplo nem sempre
é descrito como um jogo.
Na comunidade de física, por exemplo, é mais comum que
o exemplo seja descrito simplesmente como um experimento em vez de um jogo
e Alice e Bob são vistos como detectores em vez de jogadores.
A ideia básica de um experimento como este onde o entrelaçamento leva
a resultados estatísticos inconsistentes com
qualquer descrição clássica
ou mais geralmente qualquer
teoria baseada nas chamadas variáveis ocultas locais,
é devida a John Bell, o patrono dos estados de Bell,
e então as pessoas frequentemente se referem
a experimentos desse tipo como testes de Bell.
Às vezes as pessoas também
se referem ao teorema de Bell, que pode ser formulado de diferentes formas, mas basicamente diz
que a mecânica quântica
não é compatível com as chamadas teorias de variáveis ocultas locais.
O jogo ou desigualdade CHSH é essencialmente um exemplo muito bom e limpo
de um teste de Bell,
e você pode pensar sobre
este exemplo como uma prova ou uma demonstração do teorema de Bell.
O segundo comentário é que o jogo CHSH nos oferece uma forma de testar experimentalmente que a teoria da informação quântica
é uma teoria precisa. Podemos na verdade configurar experimentos que implementem o jogo CHSH,
incluindo o tipo de
estratégia baseada em entrelaçamento que acabei de descrever, e
ver se funciona, e funciona.
Isso nos fornece um alto
grau de confiança de que o entrelaçamento é real, e diferente das talvez
formas vagas ou poéticas
que tentamos criar para
explicar o entrelaçamento, o jogo ou experimento CHSH
nos dá uma forma concreta
e testável de observar o entrelaçamento.
Se isso soa importante,
é porque é, e o Prêmio Nobel de Física de 2022
reconhece exatamente isso.
O prêmio foi concedido a
Alain Aspect, John Clauser, que é o C no CHSH, e Anton Zeilinger
por experimentos com fótons entrelaçados que estabeleceram a violação
das desigualdades de Bell, ou em outras palavras, que
mostraram que estratégias quânticas
do tipo que descrevi realmente funcionam e superam estratégias clássicas.
E se você estiver interessado em
aprender mais sobre isso, encorajo você a conferir
o vídeo sobre o Teorema de Bell do meu colega Olivia Lanes,
aqui no canal do YouTube do Qiskit.
E por fim, o tópico de
jogos não locais mais geralmente é verdadeiramente fascinante, e é
uma área ativa de pesquisa
que une
física, ciência da computação e matemática pura e há ainda muitas
questões interessantes
sobre jogos não locais que
permanecem sem resposta até hoje.
E esse é o fim da aula quatro, bem como o fim da
unidade um da série sobre os Fundamentos da Informação Quântica.
A primeira aula explicou
como a informação quântica funciona para sistemas simples em isolamento, e a segunda aula explicou
como a informação quântica
funciona para múltiplos sistemas,
o que emerge de forma bastante natural da forma como funciona para sistemas simples.
A terceira aula introduziu
o modelo de circuit quântico de computação, e na quarta aula, demos uma olhada em três exemplos importantes
que ilustram coisas que
podemos fazer com entrelaçamento.
Ao longo do caminho, vimos alguns conceitos matemáticos muito importantes,
incluindo produtos tensoriais e produtos internos, e observamos
algumas limitações fundamentais
da informação quântica.
Espero que você se junte a mim para
a próxima unidade da série, que será sobre algoritmos quânticos, onde vamos nos concentrar na questão
de quais vantagens computacionais
a informação quântica oferece.
Até mais.